est ce que le directeur de la
gendarmerie trouve conforme l'image du
gendarme louis de funès veut pas tout à
fait donc c'est un gendarme l'occasion
un produit pas du tout vous contestez
d'abord ici il sait il s'est collé des
galops moi je croyais que vous n'avez
pas le droit d'être comme ça
maréchal des logis-chef d'entrée de jeu
ça c'est pas normal vous l'avez pas sur
les autres
le cursus honorum mais pas d'abord été
gendarme et puis après vous avez pris
vos galons ça c'est scandaleux doit
savoir recevoir louis de funès ce qui se
passe maintenant sur la route quand vous
faites arrêter par un gendarme ça doit
bien vous arrivez ou quand vous
rencontrez un gendarme dans la rue
qu'est ce qu'il vous dit pas que des
choses très gentil et très charmante
sont satisfaits général des ja je n'ai
jamais elle doit que ce soit par dont
ils sont satisfaits en général de
l'image que vous avez donnée d'eux je
n'ai jamais eu une critique nucléaire
fait je peux dire des compliments sur
les films comment êtes vous devenu de
gendarmes
comment avez vous fait pour vous mettre
dans la peau d'un gendarme c'est d'après
une idée d'une idée de band chic qui lui
se promener paraît-il de ce qu'ils ont
qualifié aussi il se promenait à saint
tropez et il y avait paraît-il un
gendarme soit je ne crois pas qu'ils
étaient assis à califourchon sur sa
chaise face aux envahisseurs mr enquête
lb pourquoi c'est pas contre euro et le
bon âge je ne sais pas il est facile
alors ça c'est la version balducci qui
nous a donné une bonne saison mais bon
voilà
et il y là il a dit voilà je suivre
déposé une plainte vient de me voler ma
caméra dans ma voiture et notre curé pop
vous devez vous abonner votre caméra et
des ouïes
vous tenez à faire une déposition une
banlieue on sait qui c'est on s'excuse
on n'arrive pas à attraper et la société
regarder le regard des vols à bas loyer
ou c'est celui là
mais la gendarmerie la face est parti
d'une petite histoire comme celle
d'aujourd'hui
mais comment vous êtes vous mis dans la
peau des gendarmes est ce que vous vous
êtes vous avez visité les gendarmeries
expansé a vécu avec des brigades de
gendarmerie non non j'ai pas non non non
non non non ça viendra plus tard
peut-être quand on va le mobiliser non
mais on a un peu joué sur le sur ce
qu'on connaissait des gendarmes dans la
vie oui enfin dépriment comporte pas
tous comme vous quand même je peux aussi
sont ils sont déjà en lice aux gentils
comme nous ils se passent comme vous
êtes géant rien de 804 jantes et une
attaque à la baisse oui non à notre
tâche est gagnée fléchard débouchés et
celle de saint tropez à leur entre
parenthèses est encore peu chaban très
gentil je voulais lire un tout petit mot
aussi pour le leur chef qui s'appelle de
chef olivier est un charmant garçon
c'est une recommandation dans
l'avancement ajoute bien si je voulais
bien tout petit brûlures aux jambes
doute aussi j'attends un signe qu'ils
sont bien charmant garçon si j'ai une
affaire judiciaire à l'époque avec le
maître chanteur avec menaces de mort
horrible et grâce à lui j'ai pu dormir
tranquille parce qu'il touchait chez
nous qu à agen où les gendarmes y en a
qui faisaient la ronde avec des
mitraillettes c'est olalalala le
lieutenant ces gersois qui est un
charmant garçon
donc ça fait déjà beaucoup de monde qui
sera heureux après que vous étiez
presque dans le film alors avec les
gendarmes ou gens autour de lui oui
c'est vrai vous retrouviez absolument
mais je crois que l'admr dessin pour
demain vous rencontrez paraît-il c'est
vrai quand je sais pas si c'est moi je
vais rencontrer dans la fâcherie ya un
prochain projet oui oui j'en ai entendu
parler
le dernier gendarmerie le dernier
toujours le dernier meilleur mais je ne
sais pas ce serait par exemple le film
des musées comme ça il y aurait des
motards qui viendrait chez monsieur
galabru
avec le nom galabru lui déposer eu un
pli un autre moteur qui vient chef de
file est chez grosso modo chez eux mêmes
amara christian marin oui et nous on se
réunit on se retrouve dans la direction
de la gendarmerie
si elle vient de changer l'adresse
signal et vous êtes mobilisés alors non
non croit que c'est une décoration film
en film
abdullah lors nous fait rentrer il
alliera monsieur qui fera monsieur le
directeur d'acteurs il ya des généraux
nous faire soirée en u17 filet ces
messieurs qu'anna buzz je vais vous
demander ça c'est pas ce directeur qui
par sa présence est ce que vous foutez
de nous parce que je parle pas comme ça
non
voilà voilà voilà ce que vous vous
foutez de nous alors qu'il correspondait
pas ce que vos films sont mal fichu sur
l'épaule tout jeune cascades etc cette
image que vous faites des gendarmes et
puis je vous dire j'ai fait six mois que
je ne vous aime pas du tout comme acteur
non je n'oserais pas vous dire de
pareilles choses comme ça et ensuite on
nous mettrait deux fils pendant un mois
tous devant la gendarmerie
voilà leur église est vous allez finir
par un accord avec les chiens avec
l'échec des hélicoptères les chars et de
toute la côte et il vous arrivera pas
malheur on verra
[Musique]